hey machine learners Yannick here okay
that is stolen today I want to give some
quick thoughts about online conferences
as you might know I clear this year is
fully online because of the global
situation big props to the organizers of
the conference for putting something
together in this short amount of time i
clears one of the largest machine
learning conferences and if you're not
registered you don't get access to that
website right now so today I'll just
talk about things that are public and
we'll do like analysis of what happened
when the materials are actually released
if you want to run an online conferences
they're basically two things you need to
take care of actually three one of them
is networking but it's going to be
online we're gonna have to sacrifice
that I know there are efforts but let's
be real
so there are paper presentations and
there are things like talks panels
workshops and so on for the papers in I
clear what they have is that website and
you can kind of click on each of the
papers you'll get to a sub page and
you'll find a video that the author's
uploaded which is about five minutes
long don't get the abstract and the
reviews directly they're from open
review and during the poster sessions
you'll have a chat window where you can
chat with the authors and so so people
can come there and kind of chat about
the paper at a given time what people
have pointed out here and I agree is
that watching a five minute video often
you need like two or three minutes of
that video to even see whether you're
interested in the paper which is much
longer than you would have at a poster
at a foster you could clearly see people
say they they just open the PDF and just
kind of gloss over it and that takes 30
seconds to decide whether or not you're
interested if I were to suggest an
improvement it would be also have the
authors upload a poster though at a
glance you'll be able to see what
interests you write for the talks and
the panels the talks are pre-recorded
and then there is a question and answer
session that is live
the questions are voted beforehand and
then the
most voted questions I believe will be
answered in a live session by either the
talk giver or the panel discussion is
that is the conference but what what are
we doing here I I kind of think it's a
paradoxical thing to take the live
conference and just try to map it as
close as possible to online look at
these paper poster poster sessions right
it is cool that you have all this but
now I have to go at that particular time
to chat with the authors and this is in
competition to everything else that's
happening at the same time right so
there will be a hundred papers that are
presented in a given session and now I
can go to this one and chat here but
I'll miss the chat over there of course
I can read it later but the only reason
that is in the live conference is
because everyone's just there for one
week right that's about the span you can
hold people in one place so you need to
cram things at the same time so you're
at the poster session you will miss this
poster if you go to this poster right
you just don't have time but online
we're not constrained by this so why
aren't we doing this at the same time
why aren't we doing this a synchronously
we actually have a perfect system for
doing things like this it's called
YouTube you publish a paper you can make
it you can be five minutes could be 30
minutes you put it on YouTube you link
to your paper your abstract and your
reviews you can put them in the
description and then okay there's no
live chat but there is a comment section
I appreciate all of you thank you but we
have a perfectly fine system for that to
do this in an asynchronous way I don't
see the benefit of having really this
live chat and the talks and the panels
the same thing you have you already have
pre-recorded talks what are you doing
having them compete with other things at
the same time like okay go to this
workshop but this one's happening too
right now I have to go and decide
because everything needs
crammed into this one week it just seems
to make no sense
for example on our channel machine
learning straight talk
we have guests on and we'll do reddit
threads to ask people which questions
would they like the author's or the
people that we have on to answer and
people up and down both the questions
and then we have a panel discussion we
could even do this live right on YouTube
and then record it and it will be almost
the same experience because let's be
honest if yoshua bengio is in a panel in
a live conference you'll be lucky to
even get a single question and it will
almost never happen that you'll get a
follow-up question because you're right
there live it's just not something that
is really happening I think the main
advantage of these live conferences is
the fact that you're there if you go to
a poster session the face-to-face
interaction is something very different
from a chat window you can kind of see
what the author is thinking in real time
you can ask them questions so in writing
you can always weasel out of difficult
questions or so yeah so it seems like
you you lose all the benefits of the
live conference but if you do it in this
way you retain all the bad sites namely
the crowdedness different things
competing at the same time entry fees I
get it it's a lot of work to build this
website and so on but we have YouTube
and read it and that already covers like
95 percent of what this is is doing I
always think of this I don't know if
it's a myth when the car was first
invented it still had be pulleys to pull
the horse because people were just used
to horse buggies and not cars it seems
like we're doing the same thing with
online conferences we were just so used
to the live conferences that we don't
see the mega possibilities that we have
online these are my thoughts on online
conferences if you agree disagree
leave a comment and maybe in the future
of will go to
through online conferences asynchronous
thank you for being here and what I
[Music]